I think that the the nominating
committee of the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame is so [ __ ] up and they're just so
inbred and they're so off-course I like
the only reason that I was asked to be
in it now is because they had to do a TV
show and that's all a Hall of Fame was
there is no Hall of Fame there was no
party
they didn't introduce any of the
inductees or the inductors we never saw
each other there never was a little
thing where they said hey this is the
Hall of Fame and we're raising money and
we're doing these music education
programs all the stuff it was like shut
the [ __ ] up if you don't do what we tell
you to do we're going to cut you from
the show and we go really cut us from
the show it's something I'd say all
right we're not going to cut you from
the show and you can have five tickets
for the band [ __ ] you we want tickets
for the band the wives of stuff it just
went on and it was three months of
insults and [ __ ] and the actual
event was a soundcheck that lasted 12
minutes this kind of shitty cocktail
party on the mezzanine of the arena then
was sent out to a table where I sat down
at the table and didn't know anybody and
the people that were in the front of us
never even turned around to say hi we
just sat there we went and played a
couple of numbers then off for this
press thing and the first thing that
goes like hey how do you feel that they
didn't put you in for 23 years you know
you can go like [ __ ] you [ __ ] all you
people I never was introduced to the
Black Keys I didn't know who they were
personally right I walked in through
security and there's this guy looking at
me like making goo-goo eyes at me or
something and I walk up to him and I go
what are you doing
hoodie what are you doing tonight you
know he says I'm reading your speech I
said oh great I said I can't wait to get
the [ __ ] out of here right what I said
to him yeah you know and I didn't know
who he was if we had been introduced I'm
sure we would have gotten along because
we like the same kind of music and you
know they're working musicians except
the whole thing was a setup I felt
really bad for the other bands and I
felt bad for the way they were used and
I felt really
be angry at the lack of interest by the
people that actually run this thing and
who put it together they didn't bots
they didn't show up it doesn't get any
better does it I get are you shocked
yeah it's gonna get better I'm gonna get
these guys they're gonna be sorry that
they treated all these people this way
and it's going to go on and it's going
to get better in the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame's actually going to go to
Cleveland right the museum is actually
going to mean something and the funding
they raise is actually going to be used
for music education before I'm done
what are you planning oh I can't tell
you what are you planning something I'm
planning to keep it in in the news and
I'm planning to investigate them I've
already got all their public documents
and I want to see where they're spending
the money I want to see who's being paid
I want to check it all out